كاد يفقد حياته جوعا في مناطق سيطره
الحوثيين فاستدعى اسعافه عاجلا الى تعز
لقد فضلت اسرته النزوح من اب الى المدينه
هذه بحثا عن رعايه صحيه تنقذ طفلها من
هلاك سوء التغذيه انه مؤشر الى تدهور صحي
بات يهدد حياه مئات الاطفال في المناطق
الخاضعه لسيطره الميليشيات الحوثيه
نعالج اطفالنا ما قدرناش نسوي الولد هذا
تعبان كيف حالته يعني شو تغذيه تعبان
ما اقدر تعالجه ولا قدرت تسوي شيء هذا
الطفل عنده سوء التغذيه حاد وخين يعاني من
جفاف واسهال شديد
وعنده نقص فيها الاكسجين وضربات القلب
[موسيقى]
قطعناهن تتسع اذا دائره الفقر في البلد
وتزداد معها حالات الاصابه بسوء التغذيه
الحاد ففي تعز وحدها استقبلت المستشفيات
خلال ثلاثه اشهر فقط اكثر من 5000 حاله
سبع منها فارقت الحياه ويبقى سته ملايين
طفل في اليمن على بعد خطوه واحده من
المجاعه كونهم بحاجه ماسه لدعم عاجل بحسب
تحذيرات لمنظمه اليونيسيف في خلال الربع
هذا ازدادت
الحالات الى ما يقارب الخمسه في المئه
اصبح لدينا في خلال هذه الفترات 23 الف
حاله
مترددين في في
على المستشفيات تعز في حالات وخيمه حالات
تصارع الموت
ووفقا لنتائج التصنيف المرحلي للامن
الغذائي بالمحافظه فان الوضع بات خارجا في
المدينه ومديريه الساحل الغربي خصوصا مع
انخفاض دعم المنظمات بشكل كبير وانسحاب
بعضها من الاقسام الخاصه بامراض سوء
التغذيه في مستشفيات خليفه والشقيره غربي
تعز هل سعيد العربيه تعز لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات